[Musique]
devant le palais ducal les insectes
métallique trône en bonne place au
milieu des parterres de fleurs en 2018
nos verts a obtenu de libellules au
label capitale française de la
biodiversité
une distinction pour les actions menées
afin de laisser à la nature toute sa
place en ville végétalisation entretien
éco-responsable plantation d'espèces
locales
les initiatives sont variés une démarche
globale
accompagné par valérie chambenoit
l'écoconseiller de la ville c'est les
deux milieux qui ont été retenues pour
la scène politique
un son bord de loire est une autre en
ville c'est important parce que beaucoup
de gens pensent qu à rien en ville mais
en fait non il est déjà une présence
importante de bio diversité des parcours
explicatifs ont été élaborés à
destination des promeneurs pour faire
découvrir une faune parfois
insoupçonnées il ya maintenant quelques
années nos verts travaillent sur l'arrêt
de l'utilisation des pesticides des
solutions alternatives ont petit à petit
le jour et ont permis le retour d'une
certaine biodiversité en ville plus les
actions vont être multipliées diverses
plus la biodiversité peut en sortir
grandi
[Musique]
parmi les lieux au centre des efforts le
cimetière jean gautherin il y a quelques
années encore le minéral régnait sur ses
onze hectares entre pierre tombale est
allé de graviers sans le moindre
végétales depuis trois ans la façon de
penser le lieu a changé
le fait de remettre du végétal dans les
cimetières permet aux insectes et aux
animaux aux oiseaux et c'est de pouvoir
se réapproprier l'espace depuis les
zones extérieures du cimetière au-delà
de l'aspect écologique et esthétique la
végétalisation permet aussi de freiner
l'érosion des sols
mais les habitudes sont ancrées si le
changement est accepter l'idée qu'un
cimetière entretenu est un cimetière
sans herbe n'est jamais bien loin
germain en laye quelques-unes quand même
pas parce que vous pourrez capter ces
projets qui devant la tombe de monthey
s'est très bien pensé à mettre un petit
peu de couleur et puis bon bah si tout
le monde entretient un petit peu ça sera
joli comme c'est bien plus riche et bien
mais c'est bon pour la ville il faut
donc faire preuve de pédagogie expliquer
pour changer les mentalités
ça humanise un peu se taisent pas cela
c'est l'objectif de la mairie de le
verre le plus de visiteurs possible sans
entraver l'accès aux sépultures faut que
ça soit aussi un lieu de vie
de l'autre côté de la ville le parc
rosa-bonheur offre plus de 25 hectares
de nature labellisé refuge lpo
l'association participe depuis deux ans
à la gestion de cet espace anciennes
friches et dépotoir un matériau ans n'a
prévu de garder conserver des tas de
bois ktm côté un arbre qui tombe parce
que ça peut faire des refuge pour la
faune en particulier des petits coups de
pouce pour enclencher un cercle vertueux
en favorisant la présence d'insectes de
reptiles de petits mammifères et
d'oiseaux on s'efforce de donner des
aménagements qui sont tout à fait
faisable à il ne s'agit pas de se lancer
dans des dépenses exorbitantes
mais le site se prête bien à
l'aménagement de tas de bois
aménagements également de pierre pour
faire des pierriers afin que les lizards
autres puissent venir s'abriter et leur
bien sûr il ya aussi la pose de nichoirs
[Musique]
c'est un lieu de promenade c'est un lieu
où il ya des courses d'orientation c'est
un lieu où il y admire les gens qui font
du footing les gens qui font de la
bicyclette etc
ça favorise le contact du public et de
la nature et on espère une meilleure
connaissance de la nature
il reste du travail pour parvenir à
l'harmonie entre la ville et la nature
nevers espère encore montrer l'exemple
et inventer de nouvelles façons de
conjuguer pilloud diversité et cadre de
vie de qualité